I am nowhere near as tired as the  President of the United States I have  not made that formal decision but it's  my intention my intention to run again  and we have time to make that decision  uh Dr Biden is for it  Mr President oh Dr Biden thinks that my  wife thinks that uh  that I  that were that were doing something very  important the media have been  metaphorically propping up Biden for  years they are now literally propping  him up as he appears almost to doze off  on camera you are seeing this desperate  propping reflected right now in the  polls as the midterms approach now just  over two weeks away the polls are all  breaking for republicans